Speaker 1: The other thing in the news. Related
to impropriety and not getting things done is
the Supreme Court. Famously, this summer,
there was a draft opinion leaked that told
the world that the Supreme Court was going to
overturn Roe v Wade. And in subsequent months
there's been an investigation and I use heavy,
heavy air quotes there and investigation to get
to the bottom of what took place. And then
just a few days ago, it came out that there
were we can't find the leaker. We don't know
investigation over even though they didn't
interview any of the actual justices, everybody
else involved had to sign sworn affidavits under
the penalty of perjury that they were telling
the truth. They had nothing to do with it,
but the justices didn't, nor did the justices
family, because there is no code of ethics.
There's no code of conduct for the Supreme Court.
People who make decisions that impact the lives of
360 million Americans aren't held to the same
standards that you are at your job. I'm going
to read a little bit from the CNN article entitled
Exclusive Supreme Court Did Not Disclose Financial
Relationship With expert brought in to review
leak probe. The Supreme Court did not disclose
its long standing financial ties with former
Homeland Security Secretary Michael Chertoff,
even as it touted him as an expert who
independently validated its investigation into
who leaked the draft opinion overturning Roe v
Wade. The court's inquiry released last week with
Chertoff's endorsement, failed to identify who
was responsible for the unprecedented leak. The
decision to keep the relationship with Chertoff
quiet is a reflection of a pattern of opacity at
the nation's highest court, whose rulings affect
every American. Now this relationship is worth a
million or so dollars to Michael Chertoff. They
pay him, the court pays him, has paid his firm
about $1,000,000. So the reason that this stinks
is the fact that. He has an incentive. He has
a motive to do the bidding of the Supreme Court
and sign off on this B.S. investigation, because
if he goes the other way, if he goes against
the court, that money very well could dry up.
I believe the days of holding in high esteem, the
Supreme Court of the United States are over. It is
an absolute activist MAGA court. You've got your
your Neil Gorsuch, your Sam Alito, your Clarence
Thomas, your Brett Kavanaugh. John Roberts used to
be one of the worst. And now he looks like a good
guy in comparison. It is terrible. And they're
shameless about it. They have their I mean,
the mask is off. They don't care if you know
what. I continue reading here. CNN has learned
from sources familiar with the arrangements that
the court in recent years has privately contracted
with the Chertoff, the Chertoff Group, excuse me,
for security assessments. Some broadly covering
justices safety and some specifically related
to COVID 19 protocols at the court itself. The
estimated payments to his risk assessment
firm for consultations then extended over
several months and involved a review of the
justices Homes reached at least $1,000,000.
And here we go again No transparency or opacity.
As CNN said it, the exact amount of money paid
could not be determined. Supreme Court contracts
are not covered by federal public disclosure rules
and elude tracking on public databases. They don't
have to follow the same rules that even Congress
does. And Congress doesn't have to follow the
same rules that the rest of the country does.
The justices have long cloaked themselves in
secrecy to the point of declining to respond to
questions about potential conflicts of interest
or to reveal information about some court rules
and ethics codes, or to release timely information
about the justices health and public appearances.
This is all gross. If they want to, to
maintain some air of credibility. We need
a code of ethics for the Supreme
Court. And how we get that is Congress
in the Constitution. Congress is given the
power to organize the courts. They could do
this. They could have done it last Congress.
They could have done it the Congress before.
They could have done with the Congress before.
But they sit on their hands because it is not
in their best interest to wreck. To. To. To.
To rock the boat. It's. It's all a bit much.
Again, I would love to see you subscribe to
me on YouTube. Jessie Dallimore. Follow me on
social media at Dallimore. On on Instagram, on
Twitter and Tik Tok. I'd love to see you there.